but i'm starting at bu
in january
and this is joint work with jaiwan allen
two
who just changed his last name so i got
confused uh
and he's at mit and daniel gao
who's a student of mine at bu even
though i'm not there yet
and the title of the talk is first order
iterative methods in the design of fast
factor algorithms
so let me give you a brief introduction
of what we are talking about
and we saw in the last few days
the amazing power of this laplacian
paradigm we have lots of graph problems
and we can all
in some sense reduce them to a number of
computations of solution of a std system
and you know maxwell problems graph
partitioning lots of different
fundamental graph problems uh
the picture has been this one and i kind
of
want to focus on what happens on this
arrow
it's not trivial you know how do you
turn the maximum flow problem into an
electrical flow problem
and what goes on here is actually my
favorite part because it's a very
elegant interplay of discrete
and continuous ideas you do
preconditioning which comes from the
numerical
computing world but you use a discrete
object like a spanning tree to
precondition
and what's been happening more and more
in this arrow
is the use of iterative methods from
complex optimizations
we are really starting to leverage these
methods
and understand very well what they do
and here are the the main example
probably the most famous and ubiquitous
one is multiplicative it updates
that's been popping up everywhere kind
of enthusiasts
not only in this specific framework it's
very
it's very common technique and it turns
out that it's
essentially an iterative method as you
will see uh
gradient descent and saturated methods
these are more advanced methods think of
a conjugate gradient of chebyshev method
for solving system of linear equations
and then um like as alexander
i guess was supposed to talk about but
they really didn't
interior point methods are kind of the
frontier
and for the purpose of this talk i'm
actually going to focus on the first
three of those which can be thought as
you know they're actually called black
box first order iterative methods
because
as you will see this can be stated in a
very simple black box framework
interior point method is more advanced
because it looks at the global structure
of the problem at every iteration
so we're going to keep it simple in this
talk
and yet even though we are going to keep
it simple
we'll see that these methods have an
amazing power
and these methods are not new we already
knew about multiplicative updates we
already knew about gradient descent and
there are
lots of applications already in the
theory world and in algorithms before
std solvers and before the event of the
laplacian paradigm
but now and even as a proof technique
they yielded for example the qip
equals space result strongly relies on a
version of multiplicative it updates
so they're really powerful but now they
are really coming
you know they're really showing all
their power in as part of this laplacian
paradigm
and actually for me i don't tend to
think in this way anymore
i really like to think in this way where
sometimes you don't even need to go here
sometimes the combination just
understanding your first order iterative
method
is powerful enough to give you results
that were not known before for example
i'll briefly mention some results for
packing your piece
that were not really clear before we
really started exploring this area
so the plan for this talk is that
i forgot to write this slide so the plan
for this talk
is that first i will do
i will introduce what black box
iterative methods are
and i will show you gradient descent
which is the simplest
form of such a method and
then i will talk about multiplicative
weight updates and their generalizations
and then i will show how by simply
putting together these two
bricks you can get nastrops algorithm
which is the optimal method for smooth
optimization and we'll see what that
means
and along the line i've spent quite a
bit of time on multiplicative rate
updates because i think there is kind of
a lot of interest on
what how we can interpret this method
and i will show that the generalization
or typically white update is
also interesting and it yields
interesting perspectives in other
problems for example
in specification sometimes you can do
something which is like multiplication
updates but with a different
regularizer and you'll see what it means
and get better results
anyway a lot of lots of preamble let's
get going
what does it mean to be a black box
method it means that i'm optimizing some
convex and differential functions
i'm minimizing and the only way in which
i access the input
is by querying a point x in my feasible
set and i get back
the function value and the gradient
and my goal is to query a bunch of
points and then
use somehow these queries to produce a
new point
which could be you know it could be one
of the queries so it could be an average
of them
this new this last point x out
has to be an absolute approximation to
the optimal value
and the question is how many queries of
this black box can i
use microwaves using black you're using
your black box with respect to f but
you're not necessarily a black box in
any way with respect to x that's
that kind of accepting output right now
yeah i'm not
okay it turns out that throughout this
because i want to keep my methods very
simple
x will be a very simple set on which
optimizing is trivial so f x could be
the simplex
or the fear but in general i assume that
i can solve
optimization i i have lots of power over
x
so i wouldn't if i solve a linear
program i want to put
my feasible set here i will somehow
incorporate in the definition of f
so simple set x
this model is particularly nice because
actually you can prove lower bounds for
this it's so restrictive
that it's you can actually prove
information theoretically over balance
and it's also nice because when we want
to design a fast algorithms
we want to do things that are very cheap
every iteration has to be cheap
and this property that at every
iteration we can really
you know you can really look at the
input only in terms of the function and
the gradient
is a good way of modeling what it means
for an iteration
to be cheap to be fast to be a quick
sketch of the problem
so let let's see how do we go about
analyzing
a black box model we need two things
well first we need to somehow
you know have a a procedure every way
to output this x out and have some bound
some upper bound on its value but the
same time if you want to have
it you know theoretically sound
algorithm we also have
need to have some way of certifying that
our final account is close to optimum so
these are
these are two separate goals we have
and this will be important in the course
of this talk
and i will kind of always talk about a
primal side or a primer problem
in which we try to produce a point which
has a good objective value
but also a dual side in which we try to
prove
a good lower bound on on the optimum
this will be kind of competing goals of
our of our algorithm
and last thing i need is what the
assumptions are we need some
nice assumptions on the functions we'll
be minimizing
because otherwise this you know in the
most general settings there is really
little you can do
so there are two kinds of assumptions
we'll use the most important one
is uh the notion of smoothness
which technically you can think of as
the gradient being leak sheets with
parameter
l so if you move in your space by
to go from x to y the gradient cannot
change too much you can change at most
by the distance between x and y times l
and it's a good point a good moment to
say that
throughout the stock i'm going to use
norms and you might see primal and dual
norms
if you are uncomfortable with it just
take all the norms to be l2
and everything will work if not then you
are on your own you know what you're
doing
the kind of fundamental case you should
think about which is not l2
you should think of l 1 and l
and infinity the other one will appear
i'll infinity another one
in some applications actually
essentially all norms in between
appear as well but we will not go ahead
um okay so what's why do we want
why is this useful we see that uh
essentially the fact that the gradient
changes smoothly
will allow us to do something like
gradient descent
there is another case which is more
complicated and
actually more common in our community
because it tends to arise from
combinatorial optimization problems
which is
non-smooth optimization so now what
happens is that the gradient can change
completely
at a point but what we know is that the
gradient is never too big
so these lines here never become too
steep
but they can change completely in a very
small interval
and this is actually makes things much
harder
essentially for the reason i said that
in this word
we can somehow predict what the gradient
that our next step will be
and i will show that that's enough to
make the gradient descent
works and i will i will call this a
primal approach
so in this word we'll focus on
decreasing the function value
in this word essentially gradient
descent doesn't work
because if you're at this point any kind
of gradient descent algorithm that works
has to use the norm of the gradient to
make a decision about which step length
to take
and if the function can change
completely in a closed neighborhood
you have no idea of how long how far you
should go along your gradient
and you're just you may completely
overshoot
or you may choose to move too slowly and
then you'll converge slowly
so in this method i'm saying in this
word in some sense
the idea of gradient descent does not
work at all
and it's kind of amazing that uh there
are ideas inside that
work and that rely essentially on a dual
approach
so you don't do gradient descent what
you do is
you think of this gradient not as a
suggestion in which to move your primal
solution
but as a lower bound as a hyperplane
lower bound in the function and then
you're going to query
other hyperplanes lower bound in the
function and hopefully you can
put them together into a good lower
bound
and the advantage here is that if you
know that all the upper planes you query
are not too steep
it's going gonna be easier to form this
rubber band
but it's a completely different idea
from getting descent it's a dual
technique based on improving a lower
bound
and i mean it's actually in some sense
symmetric to brilliant descent it's like
doing gradient design on the dual
but i am philosophizing
um so the outline again
i will first do the simple primal
approach and with gradient descent
for smooth optimization then i'll do
the dual approach for non-smooth
optimization
and these as many names as appears has
been discovered many times i will call
it dual averaging
and it is a generalization of
multiplicative weight updates
and it strongly relies on this notion of
regularization
and within this part of the talk we're
exploring kind of to some extent
the connection with online learning many
of us have first discovered the idea
of multiplicative updates while
discussing
online learning problems like online
linear minimization
then we'll put at the end briefly we'll
put these two together to get the primal
dual approach
which is optimal for smooth optimization
and in this slide i also gave you a
preview
of what kind of running times we'll have
just to give you an idea that no smooth
optimization is the hardest one
so if you want an absolute error you'll
need one over epsilon squared
then descent because you have it is not
this nice property this nice smooth
property
allows you to converge in one over
epsilon but for smooth optimization we
can actually do better by combining
primal and dual ideas and get to one
over square root epsilon
any questions now before i go into
brilliant descent
is one rep square optimal for the
non-smooth case in your
network yeah it is optimal and
it's the same by the the same examples
that are bad for multiplication updates
are bad for document they know most
optimization sensing
they're essentially a randomly
constructed linear function
what do you mean by arsenal
optimal in terms of the asymptotic
dependence between epsilon and the
number of iterations
so square root t epsilon will go down
like square root t and asymptotically
that's
optimal in the general case for
non-smooth optimization
and that's actually not hard to prove
just information theoretically you can
construct the family of inputs
on which you have to spend the time
so that's a great question um
in the most general setting i believe
it's zero squared but there are
if you have just a bit of structure you
can often improve the dependence on row
quite dramatically for example
for packing uh you can easily get it
down to
for lp packing of peas you can easily
get it down to row
instead of row squared and you even
remove it completely
for backing your pieces so that changes
more on the contest
but epsilon squared is kind of
used it's much harder to overcome that
it's more in-built internet
okay
so
gradient descent um so informally when
we think about readiness and we think
about
being at xt and taking a step in the
direction of the gradient at xt
as john mentioned in his talk this is
really a special instance of brilliant
descent for the
l2 for the euclidean case in um
the more general definition is that we
are gonna consider
a linear approximation to our function
at x t
so the approximation given by the
gradient
and then we are going to minimize this
linear approximation
inside a certain ball around our point
so we find we do
know we have this kind of trust region
so with this ball where we believe
the linear approximation to be
pretty pretty good and we pick the best
point
in this ball and the radius of this ball
here i'm kind of hiding liters the
radius of this ball can actually depend
on
the norm of the gradient but this is
the idea and again
we talked already a bunch of times in
this workshop
about how a lot you know quite a few of
the recent developments
in fast algorithms involve using
gradients gradient design schemes which
are not euclidean
so i think john already showed this
picture where this would be
this is the euclidean gradient descent
because we are moving
we are moving optimizing the gradient
inside the ball but in the max flow
algorithm
we use a another infinity good in
descent
yes well actually i i stole it from you
you stole it from intact
and i think intact made it but we should
ask
so smoothness is kind of fundamental
property that
will also come you know will also be
important in the next month
in the non-smooth cases so we should
really
focus a moment to understand what it is
so one way of defining smoothness is by
how the gradient changes
as you move from x to y it turns out
that this
definition is essentially equivalent to
the following
that you can upper bound
the function value at y by a quadratic
function
which is the function value at x then
the gradient approximation at x
and a quadratic term on y minus x
and this you that you just do kind of by
integrating
uh in some sense because the gradient
cannot change very quickly
the function cannot shoot
all of a sudden
and then this will be and
i'm doing all of these for convex
functions
these the same ideas work for concave
functions so the
smoothness will be defined the same way
and this sign will be different
you get that the point is at least f y
is at least
this quadratic function
so what what does how does this help in
in a picture
the red line is our objective function
which we don't know
all we know of the red line is that we
query this point we have this function
value
and this gradient and
by using the smoothness property this
allows us to recover
this quadratic function which we know
is an upper bound to our
input
the kind of the natural thing to do is
to pick
our nest update to be the minimum of
this blue function
because that gives you the largest
guaranteed decrease in objective you
don't know where the red function is
it could be exactly at the blue function
or it could be lower
but the best you can do is to go here
and it turns out that that's exactly
what gradient descent does
and in the unconstrained case
you have a guaranteed decrease in
objective which equals
this quantity which you should notice
depends on the size
of the gradient this makes sense because
if the gradient is big
and the gradient cannot change very
quickly you can take a long step
and have a big decrease in function
value
and this actually this idea the large
gradient is good for gradient descent
kind of intuitively will be important
later because i already showed you that
large gradient is kind of bad
for the non-smooth case the non-smooth
case is
is should be easier when the gradient is
small
if you remember this dual picture i
mentioned and it turns out that in some
sense
the essence between primal dual is that
you
you you want to argue that the primal as
well when the gradient is large
and the dual does well when the gradient
is small
and waving sense
okay right so let's finish the analysis
now it's pretty easy
we have a decrease in the primal
objective
so now we also need to lower bound the
optimum and this is actually usually
it's the
it's the more tricky business because
um we don't know where the optimum is
and graded descent takes a fairly naive
approach to the
question of lower bounding the optimum
what it does it just
it looks at the last type of plane
acquired
and it says you know the function has to
be above this hyperplane
and the best point can be
you know how far away can can the best
point be from me
i can just upper bound that by the
diameter
of my feasible set and then what i get
is that
my kind of distance in objective value
from the optimum
has to be less than the size of the
gradient times some notion of diameter
yeah you know it's the distance but you
can replace this with the diameter of
the set
and now i have these two equations which
relate
my improvement my progress in one
iteration and my distance from
optimum and they both involve the the
size of the gradient
so i can trade off this term and i will
get a bound like this
and r squared is exactly this kind of
notion of
and for the l2 case is just the the
distance from the initial point
to the to the optimum take it as some
notion of how big the feasible set is
and so the bound depends on l over t so
the the smoother your function is the
smaller l is
the faster you converge linearly and the
one over t means that if you want to get
epsilon convergence you need one over
epsilon iterations
it's uh you always see that lnt they
always
come they have like the same units in
some sense so
they will always come in l over t or
square root of t or
okay any questions on gradient descent
all right so you have the same units
well i'm saying that
essentially in most bounds involving
smooth optimization
um you should expect l
to always be divided by t because you
can change
your uh function you can you can you
know double it by two
um that will change the smoothness
by two but it will always also change
your epsilon requirement
uh which is kind of captured so epsilon
now what happens
which means that it must be appear like
that
sorry it's absolutely right it's not d
of course yeah t is something pretty
different
okay um
so what are the limitations reading end
why only one over epsilon
the problem is you know this bound here
is actually pretty good it's kind of the
best you can do
but this way of choosing a lower bound
is actually
not very smart for the following because
in some sense you're only using a single
hyperplane to construct your lower bound
and you will see that the the dual
methods we'll talk about
have a much smarter strategy to
construct this lower bounds
so let me quickly show conceptually what
goes wrong with a single upper plane
so this red line here is your feasible
set so it's a one-dimensional
minimization problem
and i query this point i see this
hyperplane
the best lower bound guarantee i have is
the minimum of this linear function over
the feasible set
which is this value here this is my
current lower bound
then as i keep querying my lower bound
improves
but notice that because gradient descent
wants to keep improving
the primal value as well it's very
conservative here
and the lower bound increases very
slowly
smart thing to do to improve the lower
bound would be
to query a point somewhere whose
function value might even be higher than
this one
but this would allow you to see this
kind of hyperplane
and what you do with this kind of upper
plane and this one that you saw before
you average them and you get
a nice flat lower bound to your function
so the point is that if you want
better lower bounds you must be willing
to explore
other areas of your feasible set well
you know which may have
worse function values but they give you
the gradients you want
all right so let's turn to dual
averaging
it seems if you have many weather planes
and you want to know what's the
let's have minimum high space you want
to know what's in your intersection
that seems like an hp problem right so
you're actually
you're not constructing the best
possible uh
lower bound you're just taking the
average of them
and you're giving one solution you could
start a much better lower bounds if
you're willing to optimize
over the hyperplanes you have but you're
not going to do that
i mean in some cases when you have some
structure you can choose
to throw away some microplanes for
example
but in general you take the average
um okay let's talk about dual averaging
so now we have a non-smooth problem
so this kind of problem where the
gradient can change abruptly
um i want to produce both an upper bound
and a lower bound to our function and a
way to
make queries upper bound and lower bound
that show that we converge quickly
and essentially whenever we query a
point
we get the lower bound the blue line
and an upper bound just given by the
point we queried the functional value
the upper bound of the global upper
bound you're going to use
is just the average of the function
of you know of the points required we
could choose the minimum which is
strictly better but
for the analysis we just need the
average so you know
our running upper bound on the optimum
value
is the the average value
the average objective function are the
points we queried
what's the lower bound well similar idea
actually completely
same idea we have a linear function
for each point we query so we average
them
and we know that the average must be
a lower bound to the optimum
so now we have an upper bound and a
lower bound it's a natural
thing to do to look at the duality gap
because we want
in some science these two quantities to
become close to each other
and the duality gap when you subtract
these two quantities looks like this
so it's a sum overall t's
of you know the gradient applied to
x of t minus the optimal
and then and if i lighten this
expression because
i want to draw draw a connection to
online learning right now
when i can reduce this problem to online
learning and i'm going to claim that
this
is essentially what's called what's the
regret
in online learning okay and we'll see
why
wait is that one over t in front of that
yes
good i always yes please yes
raise your hand if you find mistakes uh
yeah there is a one over t here because
i forgot the averaging
uh if you imagine this
bacteria the gradient as the loss
function at time t
then this will be the loss of my
strategy minus the loss of the best
expert
of any expert let me say that
more slowly so keep this in mind
let's think about an online setup
a line algorithm in a game a repeated
game which works this way
we play a point in our physical set we
are given a gradient
and we don't think of this gradient as a
gradient anymore
we think of it as a loss function and
then
we suffer this loss the inner product of
the loss function
and my point and we update
to a new point and the game continues
and our goal
is over time to minimize the average
regret
which is the average loss of our
algorithm
of our strategy for ping again for
picking us teeth
versus the loss of the best point
in hindsight if you are allowed to
always to
play a point in hindsight but it has to
be a fixed point
so this is a classical notion of regret
in online
learning and it's you know there are
lots of
ways to do this and to be clear now that
if you replace loss function with
gradient
of the function and it attacks t these
regret and
duality gap are the same thing so
we can solve a non-smooth optimization
problem
by forgetting that the gradients we are
seeing are gradients
throw that information away just just
taking them as
adversarial linear function and playing
an online regret game
so now i'm going to kind of go one level
deeper
and explain how these online learning
strategies
uh work to minimize regret from an
optimization point of view
so ask any questions now if you
i have
uh so this is bound i mean
regret right uh
it doesn't have to be just take this you
know x star
is whatever minimizes regret it could be
it doesn't have too many
to have to be the minimum of the
function i'm just claiming that
for all x star i can provide the
upper bound to this
you clarify just a little quantity more
about why why this is reality
i mean or what says this is duality
um in duality gap
yeah so do so where is the primal dual
pair here that we have
well yeah maybe
i'm thinking of it in terms of having a
candidate primal solution
which is the minimum of this point or
the average which has this value which
is guaranteed to have at least this
value
and a candidate dual solution which is
the average of these gradients
which i can show as this value
so what i'm asking is like
totally understand the formula but what
what what is this the dual problem of
or what i mean yeah we know what the
fuel problem is and in this case is
there is there's some optimization
problem that is
to do yes uh and we'll see that
in the next part that's how we're gonna
exactly how we're gonna proceed
and i just i think i'll
by going into the online learning i hope
to make it a bit more simpler and then
there i will introduce what the problems
are we are working on
all right so now i'm going to go into
online learning i'm going to quickly
review
what multiplicative rate updates uh in
case you forgot
they are going to be our paradigmatic
example of a dual averaging algorithm so
whenever you look at these dual
averaging proofs for the first time
think
multiplicity weight updates and then but
i'll give you
a proof that never you know the proof i
give never uses the word
yeah multiplicative it it's completely
black you know it's
more abstract
so i already presented the game i play a
point in a feasible set
i get a linear loss function i also have
some guarantee
that these loss functions
there shouldn't be gradient here these
are not too large
this is our same guarantee that comes
from the new smooth optimization
this is also called the width and
i suffer this loss and i update my point
and i got a new loss and i continue and
i want to minimize this average regret
okay
so the simplex the multiplied byte
updates is
an algorithm to do this regarding
minimization
when the feasible size is the simplex
so instead of maintaining a point in an
arbitrary complex set you're maintaining
a vector of probabilities
and you it's often thought of as a
distribution over
certain predictors certain experts
at every iteration a new set of losses
comes in and your loss is the
dot product of the probabilities and the
loss factor which in this case is a nice
interpretation as being
the expected loss if you actually
sampled from your probability
and you keep going and how does
so how does multiplicative weight
updates update the probabilities
it keeps some set of weights and at
every iteration
you for each for each expert so for each
dimension of the simplex
you change the weight by a
multiplicative factor of one minus
epsilon
to the loss of the expert
and this loss in
under some mild assumptions you can even
think about the loss being
inside the brackets one minus epsilon
loss but this is the
actual more principled way of writing it
in some sense
okay so what's the intuition here if
your expert suffers a big loss his
weight is going to become tiny
if there is no loss the weight stays the
same
and for now i think i'm assuming the
losses to be positive
and to recover the probability if you
just no you know
take probabilities proportional to the
weights
so these ways are evolving in this
multiplicative way
uh one comment about epsilon because
we'll see that all these dual averaging
methods have some sort of parameter
and the role of epsilon is that as
epsilon becomes small
the algorithm is more conservative it
doesn't kill off bad experts as fast
as epsilon becomes large it's more
aggressive and it converges faster to
the
you know it tracks the current best
expert much more closely
but will be also less smooth
so even though people you know think of
it like this usually
i find it more helpful to unravel this
recursion this definition of the weights
and actually think of the weights as one
minus epsilon
to the total loss of that expert up to
that point
and so this tells us that in some sense
we are just defining weights that follow
this function
at every point in time our weight
is an exponent it's an exponential of
the total loss of an expert
okay finally this is a regret bound that
you can show
so i'm using the notation l hat for the
loss of the algorithm
l star for the best loss in hindsight
and there are these two terms i want to
focus a moment on these two terms
this term here is a startup penalty
it goes down as t increases it's like
just some curve that you pay up front
and then goes down
and this term is fixed it depends on
raw and epsilon so you must make sure
that epsilon
is small enough to kill raw and it's
kind of just a penalty for being greedy
if you choose epsilon large which means
if you're very conservative
so if you are very aggressive this term
is going to be huge
okay so this kind of trade off between
you know you can make the startup cost
huge
and pay a small fixed cost or you can
make the startup cost small but then you
pay a big fixed cost it's something that
it's typical of these methods okay
so now let me quickly tell you how the
proof of this of this multiplicative
weight update works
because the proof of the more general
class of dual averaging methods
is exactly the same um
same line the same yes this is the same
idea
so the proof is a potential function
argument you have some potential
function which in this case is defined
like this
doesn't really matter what the details
are but what you know
is that the potential the potential
function is a good lower bound
to the loss of the best expert so now
this potential you defined
gives you a way of tracking the loss of
the best expert
and but you also know that the change
in potential is related to the loss of
your of your algorithm
so if i suffer a large loss at time t
i know that my potential has to go up
but if my potential
goes up it the the best
the last of the best expert must also go
up
so this potentially allows us to tie
together
our algorithm and the best and the best
expert
in ideal world there will be no epsilon
there
and then we would just match the loss
of best of the best expert in average
this is clearly not possible so
we must pay something here we cannot
make the potential function go up by the
same amount as our loss
okay so
let's generalize this proof technique
and
you know show dual averaging
so so now
i'm moving to the simplex from the
simplex to a general convex set
i'm using the same ideas
i want to somehow recreate this
potential function argument
and i have two properties i want to have
so i want my potential
to lower down the loss of the best
expert that's like a dual guarantee
but i also wanted to track
the algorithm's performance
and you know the most trivial and naive
thing you can do
is just say you know if you want
something that lacks the last of the
best expert
just use the last of the best expert
and so i could define my potential in
this way
and it turns out that then the update
rule
must be that you put kind of all your
weight
or that you just pick the best
the best expert or the best point as
your next
strategy as your next play
um okay so this is you know this is a
well-defined strategy
it does lower bound this potential does
lower bound the best expert
but it's kind of clear that it cannot
track the
algorithm's performance because
you know you might have two experts that
are really close
in uh in loss one of them is a bit
better if you put
all your weight on on the slightly
better one and that better one suffers a
huge loss
in that iteration my other one doesn't
suffer any loss
you have your algorithm has suffered a
huge loss but the best
expert hasn't moved the value the loss
of the best expert hasn't moved
is that clear so if that happens
so what that what that means that this
potential function is not able you know
it is not tied to the performance of the
algorithm
and somehow even though
this may be kind of tricky to see right
now
this is really the consequence of a lack
of smoothness
which makes sense because you're trying
to solve those most optimization
and i'd write it i like to think of it
in this way
instead of the potential as a just a
single quantity think of it as a
function
it's a function of the current you know
cumulative loss all the losses that came
through so far
and in some sense i want to see how this
function changes as new losses come in
and it turns out that the gradient of
this function is just
the the argument so it's in this in the
argument of the potential
which in this case is the argument uh
in this case is the best point is the
current best point
and what i'm saying is that this problem
of
failing to track the algorithm
performance is really due to the fact
that
this guy this function of phi of l
is non-smooth because i can just change
the
l i can just add the tiny loss and this
point can change completely
so the gradient can change completely if
i change the input function a bit
let me be so this kind of play violet me
and showing that you know dealing with
the smoothness is exactly
all that you need to to to fix this
problem
so how do we move we know that these
guys are non-smooth
arduous mutton thing i'll do with mutton
something there is a technique
from optimization called regularization
so you have an optimization problem it's
non-smooth
you add the regularizer this is called
thicken of regularization
with some parameter lambda and this
regularization as
you know in some sense this f has some
nice properties that transfer to the
whole problem
it could be you know it could lead to a
unique solution
it makes the problem more stable
and other interesting statistical
properties but i guess we are interested
simply
in in making this this smooth function
in terms of l
and let me just give you like a one
minute
in explanation of what regularization
does in our context
so we have this function f of c which is
just
the minimum of a linear function over
some convex
compact set
and its gradient we said it's the
argument
and we the reason why we were failing is
that this
function is non-smooth because if i
change c
to c prime even though c and c prime are
delta away
the gradient changes completely so how
do i make this smooth
i add the regularizer
and what does the regularizer do
it's a it's a strongly convex function
so do people know what that
let me quickly write what that means
strongly convex it's
kind of the similar to the mustness
in the sense that you know you have a
lower bound on your function
you know that it's at least
the linear approximation
plus a quadratic term
and when i say one strongly convex i
mean one ear
i think there is actually a type on this
slide i think i will actually use sigma
so it means in in so this is for any
norm
in the l2 world this means that the
hessian
if it exists is
as oligarchic values larger than sigma
okay
so what happens now is that these two
lines are not straight anymore but they
are curved
because the function now is strongly
convex
and what happens is that when i go from
when i do the same perturbation again
i go from c to c prime
the minimum point doesn't move so much
because in some sense what's happening
is that you know if i start at c this is
my minimum point
if i look at how well does
this point do for the new function for
the blue function
the gradient here cannot be very large
because i only
added a delta perturbation and because
my function is strongly complex
if the gradient is delta i can find the
minimum
at around this distance from my current
point
and here lambda sigma come in because
this guy f is sigma standard convex so
multiplied by lambda
this whole term is lambda sigma this
whole
term is lambda sigma strongly convex
and if you're familiar with financial
legion reality
this is just saying that if
for this kind of expressions if this
organizer here
is sigma strongly convex this function
here must be one over sigma smooth
it is like a very simple thing
okay is this picture clear this is the
whole idea
once you do this the proof is done and
it's
why because i change my potential
function
now instead of playing the minimum
instead of the potential is not the
minimum loss but it's the
regularized minimum loss with some
regularizer f and
then i actually claim that once i have
this setup
i'm done because
i can first lower bound the loss of the
best expert
my best expert just by the definition
of the potential is lower bounded by
the potential and then there is this
term here which is how big
you know this regularizer is all very
nice it change it makes the problem
smooth
but it also changes the problem and so
there is a
regularization error so now i still
overbound
the best expert but with some error
which depends on how big my f
can be
so i have this type and how do i track
how do i show that i track the
the performance of the algorithm i have
i use smooth
now i have created some smoothness of my
potential
so the changing potential is really
you know i'm thinking about this
potential function how it changes
when i add this new loss lt so this is
the cumulative loss now
i add a new term to the loss
and by using smoothness and now this is
mostly this is a concave function now so
smoothness comes with this sign you get
that this
is at least the gradient so the gradient
of my phi the the new term i added to
the to the loss functions
and some quadratic term which depends on
the smoothness
but the gradient of my potential
function it's the way i decided to
choose my next point
it's the argument if you remember
the gradient of my potential is exactly
the
my my choice of play at the next round
so what this smooth
equation says is that my changing
potential is at least the loss
of my expert minus this quantity which
is like a quadratic error it's a second
order
and it depends on how big the loss
function is
which we know it's controlled by the
width
any questions so this is kind of this is
the truth
once you get this kind of obvious that
you're done because you connected the
potential to both the best
expert the best point and the algorithm
so we showed in one iteration this
happens then just if you telescope
you get that the potential at the end is
the total loss
of our strategy plus the potential in
the beginning
minus this quantity you know this error
that we accumulated
and just by doing some calculation you
get this final bound and the regret
and this bound also has the same terms
there is a startup penalty
which is essentially you know how much
is the regularization error how much
error you introduced
when you inserted this regularizer
and then there is a term here which is
this
you know this quadratic term that we
paid at every step
so if you put it a large if you increase
the weight of your regularizer
then you pay more in the regularization
error
but you pay less at every at every round
because you're more smooth
okay so now if you got lost in the proof
you can
check in again here because i'm gonna
give you an example so how do we recover
multiplicative weight updates from this
kind of abstract
idea if you pick f to be
the entropy so if you choose
your nest probability distribution by
optimizing a trade-off of the expected
loss
and the entropy then it your update
is exactly multiplicative it updates
and the proof is exactly what i showed
you
because you can show that the entropy is
the one strongly complex function
with respect to the l1 so what i showed
you
easily you know it's a instantiation of
what i showed you is multiplicative way
to updates
now the great question is you know this
is all
well and nice but
are there any other useful applications
beyond multiple activate updates
and the answer is you know i think at
least from my point of view
i think within the tcs community
within algorithms specifically it's
recently been more affirmative because
we have lots of actually applications of
these ideas
for example we have one paper where we
show that different kind of random walks
that appear a lot in graph partitioning
and local graph partitioning
are just regularized version of the
eigenvalue problem
so you want to find a good cut in your
graph
and you know that the eigenvalue is a
good thing to look at but it doesn't
quite capture
the right the sparse cut so maybe you
want
to you know you know hedge a bit in your
computation of the eigenvalue
and keep around things that are close to
the eigenvalue as well
or inside in another way the eigenvalue
is a very unstable non-smooth object
if you change one edge in the graph the
eigenvector can change completely
but these random logs
because they are regularized versions of
the eigenvalue problem
because they solve these regularized
variations of dagging value problems
these are robust so you can change a
bunch of edges in the graph and your
each kernel will not change too much
and that's a great property to have in
iterative algorithms because you want to
say
i do an iteration now i change things a
bit and i can still control
what my graph looks like
and another recent and i think also for
maybe
very exciting applications of this is
that to specification
so it may not be obvious but we talked
about specification
and nikhil also gave some beautiful
lectures in the boot camp
and we showed that our
so dan and nikhil gave sweater
specifiers that approximate the graph
up to one plus epsilon with this number
of edges
using random sampling by effective
resistances
and one can show that this is
essentially you can
show this result by doing the stp
version and we'll triple activate
updates
and having so the edges will be the
edges you introduce in the specifiers
will be the loss functions
and you can just run the same proof in
expectation
and you exactly show this result more
precisely you can actually show the
matrix concentration bound
using that result so this was
interesting but it was kind of people
already kind of know the connection
between
weight updates and dual averaging and
concentration bounds
was more was was more interesting for us
was to try to understand
also the bats on the speed manager
vestava vapor which gets n over epsilon
square
from this dual averaging perspective
from this regularization perspective
and it turns out that we can do that and
there is a completely you know this is a
very there's a regularizer that is kind
of strange but
makes sense also based on work done in
the machine learning community
for learning in the bandit setting and
it turns out that if you choose this
regularizer
instead of the entropy you just run the
same kind of algorithm
but you put square root p here
then you get exactly the bss updates and
the same analysis goes through and
actually
if you change this half to
fractional values between half and one
you can recover essentially the same
result with a worse constant
but you can compute it faster so you get
this
faster way of producing linear size
specifiers
okay so i always go along for this talk
so in the last
uh two minutes let me show you quickly
how you got master of out of all of this
it's online i'm sorry
so first concluding mirror design the
concluding dual leveraging
by stepping back again and going back to
the optimization setting
these regret bounds now give us one over
epsilon squared convergence
uh why doesn't asteroids come in
let me tell you briefly very briefly
about nastro's algorithm
so we are in the smooth setting now
and master of algorithm achieves this
kind of guarantee
which is much better than the
gradient descent at t here and now this
is t squared
how does it work it's actually it's kind
of
it looks mysterious at first because
it's squaring points
and then at for every point it kind of
looks at two possibilities it says oh i
could go
to y by taking a radius step or i could
go to z if i take
a dual average step so think of the
multiplicative weight update step
i can either do a primal step or a dual
step
and essentially if you followed
what's really going on that in some
sense you would if the gradient is large
you would like to do a gradient step and
if the gradient is small you would like
to do a dual step
but that analysis doesn't work because
in some sense
you you cannot mix and match is the
steps you make here
so what you need to do is something a
bit different what master of does is
it takes the next point to be some kind
of combination
of a gradient and i do whatever step and
he claims that that's good enough to
make
progress on both sides it's not clear
why this should work and the original
paper is very
it's lots of algebraic computations now
let me try to see
to give you a brief picture of what's
going on
so remember the gradient descent
analysis we have this upper bound to the
function
so the orange function is the objective
function this one is an upper bound we
have at the current point because of
smoothness
this is a lower bound that we have been
constructing
by averaging our hyper planes so we are
kind of running
weight updates and gradient designs at
the same time
and this lower bound looks curved
because we also are regularizing we want
we are making smooth
and what we want to do in some sense
that at this point we have an ocean of
gap
you know we get we know that the primal
is below this point and it's above this
point
so we have this duality gap
and in some sense what happens now is
that
if i just wanted to do gradient descent
i would pick this point
improve my primal value the more as much
as possible
if i wanted to do dual averaging i would
pick this point
because this would improve my dual
variable my dual
problem and the value as much as
possible
and actually it's possible to write
bounds right this is a bit confusing but
you can actually write bounce to show
that you know if you
if you pick based on where you pick your
next point
you can get this new upper bound and
this new lower bound
and then clearly instead of picking this
point or this point
you should just pick the point which
minimizes the next duality gap
and that's exactly what nesterof does
you can actually show you can write
these two expressions
and you just um it's just a
you know a quadratic minimization
problem that tells you oh you should
pick
a very specific point and this point is
always closer to why
because this lower bound is is much
is much smoother well this upper bound
it kind of goes up very tightly
so you need to stick close to y to
make progress on the duality gap
so your the main idea is that you can
just think of it as
instead of picking x to optimize the
prime out of the dual you optimize the
quality gap
so i'm almost done the last thing i want
to say is that
from my point of view there is a kind of
a lot of value in understanding
these optimization methods beyond their
application to graph problems i think
they have applications in you know proof
as a proof technique as well for example
i think that
our work on understanding bss
is is very well motivated
as a proof technique it could have other
applications
and i'm also very interested in finding
places
where you can use these optimization
methods in a known
in a you know in a known black box way
what i mean is that
right now people just try to find a
problem say it's smooth and then solve
it using asterov
now that you i think we have a better
understanding within our community of
what the building pieces of these
algorithms are we can we can take
problems that do not fall
are not necessarily smooth but have some
nice other property
and still apply this primary dual ideas
to them
and an example that i have is the recent
work that i did with
the one allen zoo on packing and
covering where if you just apply
master of you get you cannot get better
than
one over epsilon squared and
there is no notion no way of getting
smoothness because
you can actually show that the kind of
smoothness you did is not possible
but if you always start to really
exploit the fact that back angle piece
are positive
so the constraint matrix is positive you
can get a different notion of smoothness
which is multiplicative instead of
additive and using that notion
you can apply similar primary dual ideas
to get one over epsilon
which was not known before even in the
optimization community
so i think there is a lot to be gained
by understanding the pieces of digital
methods and fitting them to different
problems
we have
just which regular riser did you use i
mean does nest drop views you said
is it depends so if you want to recover
the l2 version of nasturo you would
use the l2 norm squared nastrophin is in
is
in the more general versions of his work
as a genetic strongly complex function
which he calls the prox function that's
his name for a regularizer
so it's just using the strong convexity
constant of the function or something
the sum convex the the inverse of the
strong convexity becomes the smoothness
of this potential function